equality of outcome and equal
opportunity are two different things and
people confuse the two
free people
when given equal opportunities will be
free to make different choices and
different choices will map to the real
world in different ways and will lead to
different outcomes so some people will
do better and some won't
and they will end up with unequal
outcomes because they made unequal
choices
so you can give people equal opportunity
and you know that's things like estate
taxes help create equal opportunity
free education it helps create equal
opportunity
but equal outcome is the exact opposite
equal outcome destroys all motivation
and purpose it destroys markets destroy
signals that's the slippery slide to
communism so if you want to have a
healthy society then you give everyone
equal opportunity and say equal in
quotes because life isn't fair i mean uh
sometimes you might be born you know you
may be born with a crippling disease you
know that's not fair you might be born
in the third world that's not fair um
you might be born you know it's the
wrong parents who just didn't take care
of you the right way you may have eaten
the wrong thing or fallen down the
stairs there's no fairness in life so
there's no actually no equal but what
you can do is you can try and provide
equal resources and equal opportunities
not get too caught up in this idea of
something unfair happen to you because
that will just distract you from doing
what you can do from the things that are
under your control
and then stay away from equal outcome
equal outcome systems are awful
[Music]
do
[Music]
you